everything going on in this tent and for
that matter everything you've ever seen
with your eyes heard with your ears
touch with your fingers in your life we
understand the laws of physics that
govern what those things are this is
what we call the core theory in physics
it's the standard model of particle
physics plus Einstein's general
relativity you may have heard that
gravity which general relativity
describes does not play well with
quantum mechanics we don't have a
quantum theory of gravity and that's
true but we have a pretty good quantum
theory of gravity well we don't have is
the final quantum theory of gravity
we can't explain the Big Bang or black
holes but if you want to explain why
raindrops fall down rather than up you
can explain that in both quantum and
gravitational terms right now so
everything that you've ever seen or
touched we have a theory that explains
that of course we don't understand dark
matter dark energy the origin of the
universe and we certainly don't
understand how these individual bits and
pieces come together to make things like
chemicals or aardvarks or financial
systems and so forth
okay complex phenomena that are beyond
the laws of fundamental physics we
certainly have a lot to do in
understanding them but whatever that
work will eventually be it better be
compatible with the fundamental laws of
physics I don't understand how the human
brain works in any great detail but I
know the brain is made of atoms so if
I'm gonna come up with a theory of how
the brain works it better be compatible
with the known laws of physics now I
know what I know what you're thinking
I would only believe it if they showed
me the underlying equations you've come
to the right place here you go the good
news is it's only one equation okay in
Isaac Newton's time it was at equals MA
Newton's second law forces mass times
acceleration if you were Laplace is
demon in a classical world so someone
gave you the billiard balls the laws of
physics you would have in your brain
were Newton's laws and you would know
how the billiard balls bumped into each
other if you are a modern quantum
mechanical laplace's demon using the
core theory to do your predictions this
is the equation you would use and
basically this is the
that plays the role of Newton's second
law this is the answer to the question
if you give me the state of the universe
now what will it be a moment from now
what would I predict would come next now
that's not remarkable I mean this is
remarkable this is an enormous amount of
effort that goes into this one little
tiny expression right here the
remarkable thing is that I'm saying that
it's not that there's nothing missing
it's not that we're done in any sense
but if there is anything missing which
they're almost certainly is that there
are new laws of physics new fields and
particles we haven't yet discovered they
don't affect our everyday lives they
don't affect what is happening in this
room right now there's dark matter for
example very probably there are dark
matter particles streaming through this
room when I say very probably that's
because these dark matter particles must
be very very hard to detect otherwise we
would have detected them by now we've
been looking for them any new kind of
stuff that is not subsumed to this
equation is hard to detect and therefore
can't have an enormous impact on what is
going on in our bodies and our brains in
the floor in the rain etc
you